i wanted to show you a bunch of
interesting curves that you can draw and
actually i wanted to get my plotter
machine
uh working on some number fellow brown
paper and do some of the drawing for us
well i wanted to talk a bit about
something called turtle graphics which
is something you said you're familiar
with from school right um
where you
are basically controlling a little
turtle robot as it moves around on
screen drawing pictures what are the
instructions you can give to the turtle
you can go forward some distance d say
you can turn an angle
theta
and then the other thing you can do is
you can say pen
down
and pen up
pen down is you're imagining this little
turtle has a pen in the middle of it
and when pen is down and it goes forward
it will end up drawing a line as it
moves
but as the pen is up it will just move
over to that new location no line drawn
so you do like a little example i
suppose of a simple program that you
might give the turtle and we'll start
we'll go forward
one unit
i will turn
90 degrees
forward one
turn
90 degrees
forward
one
turn
90 degrees
uh forward
one even i know what's going on there
yeah i reckon you've drawn a square yeah
i think so literally check all right
cool so i've made this um little turtle
thing out of a
top of a pringles can a can of
hyperbolic paraboloids our first
instruction was forward one that means
we're going to end up there and the pen
was down so we've drawn that line behind
it
and now we're turning 90 degrees
which would be like this so our new
point is going to be there when we go
forward one
and the pen drew behind us turn 90
degrees again forward one
forward one pen was drawing the whole
time you're right we do a square and you
can get more elaborate than this yes but
i'm interested in things that are still
quite simple programs
but make more elaborate curves i've got
a version of this running um
on mathematica so if i do 90 degree
we can visualize what the turtle was
doing
so it started off going forward
turn 90
forward turn 90 forward
turn 90 forward i turned right 90 that's
turning left 90. so from now on i'm
going to just assume that after every
turn there's a there's a forward one
and i'm always going to just assume the
pen is down the whole time
so actually this program right here we
could just write as 90
90 90.
so it's even simpler right we're just
gonna have a list of angles
and see what we can draw with a list of
angles so for example let's let's say
theta is one degree
and our program is just going to be
theta
2 theta
3 theta
4 theta
5 theta just keep doing that again again
like what what do we get so i could do
that manually i could just put in one
degree two degrees three degrees four
degrees so i would just put in in here
and see what we get okay it's gone it's
going to be slightly curving up as it
goes
kind of makes sense i guess so that's
one degree above now it's going another
two degrees turn another three
very gradual
so let's let's make this more automatic
so let's do like 180 steps and we
multiply by what a degree is and this is
what we end up with as it gets tighter
and tighter
it spirals into the middle
let's do more steps let's do 360 of
these steps so what's happened here is
that the turtle's gone into the middle
and then it's ended up spiraling
back out the way it came
so at the end it's very small
but at the end it's
pointing
back from where it started it's rotated
180 degrees
so now it's ready to go up and do the
same thing over here
so if we set this theta to one degree
we're just going to get this repeating
[Music]
thing
where the turtle's going to go around
spiral come back exactly the way it came
go in spiral come back exactly the way
it came this is very similar to
something that's called an euler spiral
also called a carnous spiral but those
spirals are defined like in a continuous
way whereas this is all by taking
discrete turns
what happened here is because we're
doing exactly one degree and one degree
is a 360th of a full turn so we ended up
going back to where we started but we
can get more interesting pictures if we
make it not a
like nice multiple a nice divider of a
full turn now what if we turned 1.02
degrees each time and now
we end up
not quite coming back where we started
we do all these
dancing around and it's very sensitive
to what you you change that number to so
this is 1.03 it's a totally different
picture
it's kind of like getting back to ideas
of chaos
where this
is very sensitive where you're going to
end up after a long time is just very
sensitive on that
little number there because you can come
out the spiral kind of in a new random
direction so we could we could play with
uh this a little bit maybe so i'm going
to say we're going x degrees each time
and i get going to vary what x is so
this is going one degree each time this
is original picture
and then as i change this slider i'll be
changing number of degrees so here we go
a different picture each time as it
increments
wow
yeah
very cool so
shall we get the machine to draw one of
those for us yeah cool
so here i've got code that does
the same thing in python and it's what
it will do is it will generate
instructions which will send over this
usb to the machine and it will tell the
pen what to do in this code i've called
this d
th which is d theta like the change in
theta each time and looks like i've set
d theta to
this number here there's a number i
figured out is good because it stays on
the paper right you don't have a
guarantee that um you're not just going
to go off and like go off the paper
here's the final product well we
actually cut it off a little bit early
because we got
impatient
but this is the first few spirals of
this one here
let's have a look at what it would have
been if we let it run for for a bit
longer here is what it would have done
if we did it for ten thousand steps
um
[Music]
so yeah let's see
can we match that up a little bit
we got some of these guys going but then
it was going to kind of come out and go
right here we basically stopped after
roughly a thousand steps it looks like
we did ten thousand
then like it's kind of making a spiral
of
spirals itself
you can see this pattern
it's kind of recreating itself and going
out there
so let's do a hundred thousand so there
there you go
oh so now this is starting to look like
it's odin it's kind of macro scale
version of uh of a not
it's an oily spiral of euler spirals but
we didn't manage to get the next level
this looks kind of chaotic that would
have been a huge piece of paper yeah
yeah it would be
can you yeah look at this so it's the
side by side scale comparison
so that thing you're holding where's
that on the big picture though it's one
of those little it's gonna be one of
these little yeah hubs so now
i want to draw a sierpinski triangle
picture this one's actually called the
arrowhead curve so this is the kind of
picture that we're going to kind of try
and end up with and it's nice for the
plotter because it draws a whole kind of
sierpinski shape all in one path so you
can see it starts up here it'll end up
drawing you know this triangle and this
triangle this triangle that ends up here
you never have to do pen up that's right
it's all it's all penned down and each
step size is the same and it's all just
turning left and right
it's always either turning right um 60
degrees or left 60 degrees and so it's
just how do you come up with the list of
left right right right left right left
left that comes up with this picture
and there's a kind of interesting way of
deriving what those instructions should
be we're going to do something called
like a substitution system where we're
going to making repeated substitutions
and we'll just have two rules
so we're going to have every time we see
an x we're going to substitute it with y
plus
x
plus y
and every time we see a y we're going to
replace it with
x minus y
minus x
and
here these aren't actually plus and
minuses plus means you know turn right
and minus means to uh turn left 60
degrees and we're just going to start
you know iteration one we just start
with x this doesn't have any
instructions in it but we're just going
to keep applying these rules and see
what happens
so at step two
you know we're reading this and we see
an x so we replace it with
what we're supposed to replace it with y
plus x
plus
y
and so now if we were to do this
instructions it just says turn right 60
turn right 60. which is not super
interesting
picture
but you know we'll say we've got
we've gone forward
we turn
[Music]
turn right 60 i mean we go down like
this
and then we do another turn right 60.
and i've just drawn this picture
not very interesting yet
let's do it again so now we're going to
use this other rule for y
so we're reading y
we replace it with what we're supposed
to replace it with x minus y minus x
we see the plus that doesn't have any
replacement rule so we just copy it down
we see an x
so we replace this y plus x plus y
we see our plus so we copy it let's see
a y so we
bring down x minus y minus x which is
the rule for y
um
so now we could try and draw what this
is like i'm not going to do any i don't
want to do any more turning right and
left by 60 degrees
um
by hand so what i've done is i've
prepared a grid that should help
so this isn't cheating right this is
using a pen on brown paper i just
we used the machine to create this so
this is fine
i didn't i didn't print this within the
rules of number five i'm going to say
like we'll let's start going forward
first
and then we'll and then we'll do these
instructions
so we're going to turn left
and then turn left again
now we have to turn right
turn right again
turn right turn right
turn left
turn left
so we've created this
image here
it's kind of getting closer to a
triangle maybe it's kind of triangular
shape but it's still not got the detail
of this sierpinski triangle
yeah let's do it again
this this one had one
x this had three x's and y's this had
nine x's and y's
next one's gonna have 27 x's and y's
so let's do it one more time
there we go
i think that's right
and yeah if we did another time we'd end
up with 81 which is not going to be good
to do by hand
but i think we can try and draw
this iteration by hand okay and then
maybe we'll recruit the plotter to help
us with the next step
and
what we're saying minus was turning left
and plus was turning right
so
so we've gone forward one turning right
means that we're gonna turn right along
here
ah a few
so that looks like um getting closer to
this triangles inside triangles luke of
the sierpinski fractal
we got up to was this n equals three
picture here
i've just programmed this this what we
were doing by hand into mathematic here
because you've got a substitution system
where x is b and y there's a rule for x
and y
and instead of plus and minus i've just
put in the angles
directly in radians of pi by 3 pi by 3
for the where we had pluses and minus pi
by 3 minus pi by 3 for where we had
minuses the next step up would be n
equals 4.
so you know
we've got our what we just drew by hand
copied three times in each side
and then equals five
getting more and more detailed
and
n equals six is nice
and here's a picture for n equals 7
which might be a good one to
plot
with the machine
[Music]
okay so we've stopped the machine
exactly halfway through drawing this uh
sierpinski turtle program just wanted to
show you something um about
how it's doing the drawing
so here is halfway and um maybe if you
look at it like this because if we
reflected this whole thing over here
we'd have the full picture right
and this is just the vertical
half of the picture
um but yeah looking at from here i can
see each of the previous iterations kind
of lined up one after the other right so
um we drew
this one and this one by hand then we
bailed and we started going to the
computer
and you know these are the previous
iterations now we're going to draw the
one on top of that
so what we've seen is that
the next iteration of this arrow head
curve this arrow heads here at pinsky
curve
you could do it just by taking all the
previous iterations lining them up and
then reflecting it um
in sort of vertical axis
so if we make it draw the rest of the
picture yes please yeah cool
[Music]
so now i want to show you another type
of turtle program we can send to the to
the plotter machine like what if i just
start sending the digits of pi